?
Das war's für heute, wir sehen uns beim nächsten Mal wieder, bis dahin, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss.
So.
Das ist immer, mein Herz hat es komplett verknotet, wie geht das eigentlich immer?
Wir schaffen es, Kabel, die einfach nur rumliegen, sich zu verknoten, das geht doch eigentlich überhaupt nicht.
Naja, ist halt verknotet, ich meine, okay.
Okay.
Also, Leute, ich habe übrigens gestern noch was rausgekriegt, und zwar mich doch drüber beschwert, dass in Visual Studio auf meinem Main-Account, also nicht auf meinem Streaming-Windows-Account, dass das zu langsam ist.
Und ich habe festgestellt, die Geschwindigkeit von Visual Studio beziehungsweise die Autocompletion in Visual Studio ist, jetzt haltet euch fest, hängt direkt damit zusammen, wie viele Desktop-Icons man hat.
Ist jetzt kein Witz?
Ist echt kein Witz?
Auf meinem Haupt-Account habe ich quasi so viele Sachen auf dem Desktop, dass es ist komplett voll. Ja, ich benutze meinen Desktop eigentlich so als, wo alles hingeht, bis ich irgendwann merke, ja echt jetzt.
Wir können das mal ausprobieren, wir probieren das mal aus.
Wir probieren das mal aus, also.
Passt mal auf, wir machen jetzt einfach mal irgendwie.
Ich mache jetzt einfach das mal von gestern auf, wir programmieren jetzt nichts, aber ich zeige euch mal einfach, wie schnell das hier ist.
So.
Passt mal auf.
Guck mal, wenn ihr das hier, sorry.
Fuck.
Jetzt.
Hallo?
Hallo? Mein Backspace geht nicht.
Backspace geht nicht.
What the fuck?
Wenn es, hier ist relativ, hier läuft es jetzt relativ gut.
Und auch die neuen Sachen, die aufpoppen sollen. Jetzt machen wir mal den Desktop voll. Jetzt passt mal auf.
Mit was machen wir den Desktop voll? Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob es egal ist, mit was man den Desktop voll macht.
Oder ob man, weil ich hatte zum größten Teil Audioaufnahmen drauf.
Okay, ich dupliziere jetzt einfach mal das Bild von meiner Katze.
Spatzen wir ab.
Ich kopiere jetzt einfach das...
Alter.
Windows, herrlich.
Ich kopiere jetzt einfach mal das Bild von meiner Katze dahin.
Okay.
Dann gucken wir uns das an.
Man sieht schon, wie laggy der Ordner wird, ne?
Warum sowas überhaupt lag verursacht, ist schon...
Seht ihr, wie sehr das rumlaggt, Alter?
Weil er einfach nur ein paar Dateien kopiert.
Guck mal, das ist übelst, sogar die Darstellung im Explorer ist übelst am laggen.
Der Explorer reagiert nicht mehr.
Wegen ein paar Desktop-Icons.
Und ich hatte da wirklich... Guckt euch das mal an, der macht nichts mehr.
Der ist komplett rip.
Der Explorer wegen ein paar Desktop-Icons hier.
Seht ihr das?
Das ist mega fake.
Und ich hatte noch viel mehr drauf, ne?
Das reicht immer noch nicht.
Das reicht noch nicht, weil ich hatte viel mehr auf meinem Desktop.
Da hat sich zwei Jahre Audioaufnahmen, zwei Jahre Download, alles angesammelt auf meinem Desktop.
Also ich hatte wahrscheinlich so 2000 Dinge auf dem Desktop oder so.
Guckt euch das mal an, jetzt hab ich das kopiert.
Jetzt geht schon mal gar nichts mehr.
Boah, rip.
Desktop-Icons, der Performance-Killer unter Windows Nummer 1.
Das sind 762 Stück.
Ja und, was sind 762?
So, noch einmal einfügen.
Was sind 762 Dateien, ist das nix?
Hast du irgendein Desktop-Synchzeugs?
Ah, nö.
Ich hab einen Nextcloud-Ordner, den ich synke.
Da ist aber bloß Notizen und ein bisschen Kram drin.
So, okay, jetzt haben wir den Desktop voll gemacht.
Warum macht man das?
Weil der Desktop die beste Ablage ist für alles.
So, und jetzt machen wir mal Wishlist Studio auf.
Und jetzt passt mal auf.
Und jetzt ist wahrscheinlich...
Jetzt hoffe ich, dass mein Backspace wieder funktioniert.
Das falsche Wishlist Studio ist das übrigens.
War nur 2019 betroffen, lustigerweise.
Wo ist denn der Rest von meinem Startmenü?
Darf ich jetzt wieder Backspace drücken?
Ja!
Guck mal!
Jetzt lagts übelst.
Naja, wobei.
Ah, ich weiß nicht.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das was damit zu tun hat.
Doch!
Guck mal!
Ah, ne Moment, mein Backspace...
Sag mal!
Warum ist in Wishlist Studio mein Backspace kaputt?
Wollen die mich verarschen?
Hallo?
Warum geht Backspace nicht mehr?
Ich weiß nicht.
Das ist total lange geblieben.
Mein Backspace ist kaputt.
Aber Backspace hier funktioniert.
Fuck, Alter.
Geht Backspace in 2017?
Nee, auch...
Warum ist mein Backspace in Wishlist Studio kaputt?
WTF?
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass das möglich ist.
Backspace not working.
remembered
Start
Grass
Was?
chenkt Enter
Da
Das glaub ich nicht, dass das funktioniert.
Aber manche Windows-Geschichten sind schon echt hardcore kaputt.
Nee, Alt-Enter bringt nix.
Wenn man Solutions öffnet, wo Ordner auf sind.
Kann ich mir eigentlich gar nicht vorstellen, dass das was der witzigste ist.
Übrigens, der Explorer ist auch mega langsam, wenn man so viele Desktop-Bilder hat.
Also das scheint komplett, das scheint, guckt euch das mal an.
Wo ist das Problem?
Ich meine, okay, das sind 750 Sachen auf dem Desktop, ja.
750 Sachen auf dem Desktop, das hat man normalerweise nicht, aber das ist auch nicht annähernd die
Menge, wo ich sagen würde, das sollte Probleme machen.
Hier funktioniert Backspace, guckt, hier funktioniert Backspace.
Oh nein, die SensKey teilweise liegt, aber nicht alles, den kann man damit nicht anfangen.
Der Backspace ist kaputt, what the fuck Microsoft, was ist denn hier wieder los?
Okay, kein Bock jetzt, ich lösche jetzt erstmal vom Desktop, wollen wir mal gucken, ob Backspace
wieder geht, wenn ich alle Bilder von der Katze vom Desktop lösche.
Bis auf eins.
Okay, jetzt ist der Desktop wieder ein bisschen leerer, erstmal alles löschen, wer da löscht?
Machen wir mal was anderes auf, nee der Backspace ist kaputt, ich wusste gar nicht, dass das
funktioniert.
Ich mein, hallo, sogar in Notepad geht man in Backspace, warum, was, okay, das kann er
nicht, warum sollte sich das resetten?
Okay, Tools, Options, Environments, lösche ich jetzt mal mal, ich will, dass mein Backspace
wieder funktioniert.
Tools, Options, Environments, eboard, reset, yes, geht wieder, funktioniert wieder, Backspace
ist wieder da, Muschel Studio hat einfach mal mein Backspace gelöscht, einfach so, weil
es geht, weiß nicht, einfach weil es gedacht hat, es ist eine gute Idee jetzt, wir löschen
jetzt, wir löschen jetzt, dass der Max-Tex löschen kann, glaub ich so, das kann doch
mal passieren.
Hardware, was, nee, nicht, hat mit Hardware-Tool nichts zu tun, ich glaube nicht, dass das
Hardware-Tool etwas damit zu tun hat, dass mein Backspace immer funktioniert, das wär's
jetzt, so advanced GUI-Technologie von vor 20 Jahren, dass der Backspace kaputt ist,
es gibt eh so viele Sachen, die mir an Windows auf den Keks gehen, auf der anderen Seite,
das ist ein gutes Stichwort, zwar hab ich ein Video gefunden, und zwar von einem ehemaligen
Microsoft-Mitarbeiter, arbeitet ihr agil bei euch, das ist schwierig zu sagen, wir sagen
gerne, dass wir agil arbeiten, ohne agil zu arbeiten, also ihr kennt das ja wahrscheinlich,
es kennt wahrscheinlich jeder, der bei einem bisschen größeren Laden arbeitet, dass immer
relativ viel gesagt wird, und dann ist dann anders gemacht wird, also ich geh mal davon
aus, das ist bei allen größeren Sachen so, zumindest bei meinem aktuellen Arbeitgeber
und bei dem davor ist das so, da wird immer ganz viel erzählt, wenn der Tag lang ist,
er sagt immer, wir müssen jetzt hier agiler werden, und wir müssen jetzt hier das, und
wir müssen jetzt hier jenes, und da guckst du dich schon an, denk dir, okay, das müssen
wir jetzt genauso wie die letzten 30 mal vorher, und irgendwann, ein halbes Jahr später hörst
du nix mehr von.
Ja, ich mach nochmal den Stream, wenn das Tool fertig ist, ich muss das jetzt erstmal
in Ruhe fertig machen.
Bist du ein Ehrenmann, nein, ich bin ein Big Brain Mann, mach dir deine Arbeit Spaß
zum größten Teil schon, ich weiß, du hast immer ein paar Dinge, die nerven, das hast
du überall, aber an sich ist ganz okay, also es ist jetzt nicht so, dass ich sagen würde,
ich muss jetzt unbedingt woanders hin, ich guck natürlich immer mal ab und zu ein bisschen,
was es so an Stellenanzeigen gibt, ja, einfach um zu schauen, was Sache ist, zumal ich jetzt
ja auch nicht mehr wirklich gebunden bin, in Form von, dass ich irgendwas verlieren
würde.
Ich hab euch ja erzählt, ich hab jetzt so einen Teil von dieser betrieblichen Altersvorsorge
da abgeschlossen, da musst du halt eine Weile dabei bleiben, dass es dann nicht mehr verfallen
kann, aber das ist mittlerweile schon nicht mehr verfallbar, deswegen, ich bin da auch
nicht dran, aber ich hab jetzt nicht so großartiges Interesse woanders hinzugehen, ich mein,
es sei denn, es kommt natürlich ein übertrieben geiles Angebot in eine übertrieben geile
Firma und so, aber selbst da muss man immer sagen, das Gras ist auf der anderen Seite
ja immer grüner.
Also vieles sieht von außen geil aus und ist es dann nicht, und was ich halt richtig
beknackt finde, das, was ich so richtig beknackt finde, sind diese ganzen Werbevideos von unterschiedlichen
Unternehmen, so, Working at, was hat man da hier, Working at, keine Ahnung, war das Netflix,
genau und dann siehst du da, siehst du da so Sachen, und dann war das Working at über,
ich hab von einem dieser komischen Videos gesehen, also wo sie zeigen wie geil sie sind,
und ich hab das geguckt und hab mir gedacht, ok, das hat niemand, der wirklich in der IT
arbeitet, auf Plausibilität gecheckt, das war so ein Werbevideo, wo sie dann irgendeine
Programmiererin hatten, wo es, ich will nicht ausschließen, dass es dort auch Programmiererinnen
gibt, aber man muss halt sagen, vor allem IT und so, 90% sind Typen, aber ok, ich mein,
kann man ja ein Video drüber machen, aber was sie dann da gezeigt haben, ich muss mal
gucken, ob ich dieses Video finde, das war Working at, ich weiß nicht, Working at Netflix,
Working at über, Working at Software Engineer, Amazon, aber das war auf jeden Fall mit irgendeiner
Asiatin, das weiß ich noch, zumindest haben sie in dem Video erzählt, so nach dem Motto,
ja, First Edition, das ist das Video, aber nicht von ihm, wobei den guck ich ab und zu
auch ganz gern, sondern, gucken wir mal, ob er die Videos verlinkt hat, das Video ist
da dabei, wo sie dann gezeigt, genau, genau, dieses Video meine ich, was ist das denn,
Working at, das ist total, total, total weltfremd, was für ein Video guckt er denn da, ich mein,
das ist übrigens ein Video, wie man in der IT arbeitet, wobei, wir können uns das Video
eigentlich angucken, der macht echt ganz coole Videos, zumindest in dem eigentlichen Video,
wo es darum ging, haben sie halt so gezeigt, nach dem Motto, ja ok, so toll ist es bei
uns zu arbeiten, A Day in the Life of a Software Engineer, das ist es aber glaube ich nicht,
Google, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, zumindest war das, das da, at Airbnb, genau, das da,
das ist so richtig krass realitätsfremd, warte mal, das ist so krass realitätsfremd,
ey, also ich mein, erstens, die meisten Leute stehen gar nicht, also ich zumindest stehe
nicht auf, wenn es hell ist, aber ok, das kann ja auch im Sommer sein, das ist so realitätsfern,
ok, ja gut, bis dahin, ja, das passt ja noch, das ist ja nicht jobabhängig, vor allem diese
superfröhliche Musik morgens, das ist auch immer so eine Sache, niemand, niemand steht
morgens auf, so, ich geh jetzt arbeiten, yeah, du hast es geil, ich darf jetzt arbeiten,
kein Mensch macht das, das ist so unglaublich beknackt, aber in den Videos tun sie immer
so, als freuen sich alle so wahnsinnig dahin zu gehen, das pfeifen muss ich nochmal üben,
ich kann jetzt nicht pfeifen, weil das übertrieben laut ist, wenn ich euch ins Ohr pfeife, doch
ich, ja, genau, ihr müsst mal achtet mal in dem Video drauf, wie viel sie wirklich
arbeitet, ihr müsst mal drauf achten, wie viel sie wirklich arbeitet von ihrem Arbeitstag,
also allein schon diese Open Workspace Geschichte geht mir mega auf den Sack, also ich hab
hier schon bei uns Bedenken, was Großraumbüros angeht, aber wir gucken jetzt erstmal weiter,
wie sie sich freuen, jawoll, erstmal schuld, das ist tatsächlich ganz cool, wenn es da
Frühstück gibt, warum nicht, gut, ich mein, erstmal auf die Arbeit, ne Runde Futter,
dann E-Mails, schenkt das ja nicht verkehrt, ja, Watertime, was auch immer, was, ich weiß
nicht, was es ist, Cornflakes oder so, also sie ist jetzt schon fast eine Stunde auf der
Arbeit, ne, hat noch nichts, oh, oh, sie arbeitet, sie arbeitet, 8.45 Uhr, merkt euch das, sie
wird nicht mehr so oft vorkommen im Video, dann mal ne Runde stehen, mal ne Runde Kaffee
trinken zusammen, ja, oh guck mal, noch mal gearbeitet, ok, äh, Spoiler, ich glaube,
das wars jetzt, wo sie gearbeitet hat den ganzen Tag, also von 8.30 Uhr bis 10 Uhr und
von 11 Uhr bis 12 Uhr oder so, was gucken wir, wir gucken, wie realistisch diese Videos
sind, so, dann geht erstmal ne Runde futtern, äh, Muscheln, Alter, so, dann wird ne Runde,
was auch immer gemacht, erstmal ne Runde abgechillsort, erstmal ne schöne Runde futtern und dann was
auch immer machen, nicht arbeiten auf jeden Fall, so, dann steht ein bisschen rum, also
erstens, ihr müsst mal drauf achten, wieviel die arbeitet und ihr müsst mal drauf achten,
wie lang die, wie lang die auf der Arbeit ist, oh, ich bin wieder ein bisschen getrunken,
also im Prinzip besteht der Tag nur aus, wir stehen rum und trinken Kaffee und spielen
ein bisschen mit Hunden und, aber jetzt auch mal gesnackt, guck mal, es ist, es ist fucking
17.10 Uhr schon mittlerweile, 17.10 Uhr Snacktime, die war um 7.45 Uhr oder so auf der Arbeit,
was macht die überhaupt noch da, ist, ist ernst gemeinte Frage, ja, noch mal ein bisschen
mit den Hunden spielen, ja, das sieht auch nicht wirklich aus, als würde es aus arbeiten,
da wird noch, um 18.30 Uhr, um 18.30 Uhr wird noch ein bisschen Schach gespielt mit den
Kollegen, ja, und dann um 18.50 Uhr gehen wir erstmal noch eine Runde Gewicht heben,
dann gehen wir nochmal eine Runde Wein trinken, hat natürlich so viel mit der Arbeit zu tun,
und dann gehen wir nochmal was futtern, die sind den ganzen Tag am Essen, es ist, es ist
21, es ist 21.05 Uhr, na gut, die ist hier, also hier ist sie heimgegangen, also die ist
heimgegangen, quasi hier um, was ist denn das, 18.00 Uhr, 19.00 Uhr, 19.00 Uhr, das heißt
die war von 7, die war 12 Stunden auf der Arbeit, 12 Stunden oder, nee, doch, oder,
also, 11, die ist ja ein bisschen später hingegangen, sagen wir mal, sie war 11 bis 12 Stunden auf
der Arbeit, und davon hat die wie oft was programmiert, 2 Stunden, irgendwie so, oder
2.30, und der Rest, der Rest ist so, wir hängen mit den Leuten rum, trinken Kaffee, essen
ein bisschen was, die hat im Prinzip den ganzen Tag nichts gearbeitet, also ok, die ist 7
Uhr aufgestanden, ist, wann ist sie wieder daheim, 21.40 Uhr, ich, hallo, ich meine,
das ganze Leben besteht noch aus ein bisschen mehr, als, irgendwie, von morgens bis abends
irgendwie was mit der Arbeit zu tun zu haben, Max, du redest hier ziemlich quatsch, tja,
erhelle uns, erhelle uns, also ich weiß nicht, das sieht zwar cool aus in den Videos immer,
findest du den Job des Product Owners attraktiv, das ist immer Definitionssache, übrigens
der Job, der wäre übrigens auch was für mich, weil im Prinzip, ist sie den ganzen
Tag nur am futtern, ist halt der amerikanische Ansatz, ich glaube nicht, dass es der amerikanische
Ansatz ist, weil die Leute es so geil finden, sondern weil sich manche Unternehmen ausgedacht
haben, es ist eine tolle Geschichte, wenn die Leute quasi 24-7 freiwillig zur Verfügung
stehen.
Hier hat sie ein Paus gemacht, fand ich einmal kacken, ich glaube, das haben sie, das haben
sie weggelassen.
Hier hat sich nur die Snacks und Kaffee kurz geholt und dann ist wieder zurück an die
Arbeit, tja, wenn das so wäre, das ist wahrscheinlich auch so, das ist wahrscheinlich auch so,
aber die Frage ist, wie sie das in dem Video darstellen wollen und in dem Video wird das
definitiv nicht so dargestellt, als hätte sie gearbeitet, wahrscheinlich hat die tatsächlich
an dem Tag mehr gearbeitet, aber so wie das hier dargestellt wird, auch von einem zeitlichen
Abfall her, ist die, wenn es hoch kommt, zwei Stunden am Arbeiten.
Das ist das Ziel, natürlich ist es das Ziel, das Ziel ist, dass es so aussieht, als wäre
das ganz besonders toll und natürlich auch richtig geil und super, also voll allgemein
akzeptiert und alles, dass man quasi 24-7 für die Firma da ist, aber es gibt viele
solcher Werbevideos und die sind alle ziemlich weit weg von der Geschichte.
This is not real, das Video von ihm habe ich auch schonmal geguckt, der macht eigentlich
teilweise hier ganz, ganz, ganz gute Videos, wenn es um IT und Jobs geht, wobei man sagen
muss, das ist natürlich der Amisicht der Dinge, ja.
Die haben ja bei, war das bei Google, wo du sogar da wohnen kannst und quasi auch sogar
deine Familie dahin umziehen kann.
Das Video ist in etwa das Äquivalent zu einer Burger Werbung, die sehen in echt auch nie
so aus wie in der Werbung.
Ja, aber wusstet ihr, dass McDonalds eine super Erklärung dafür hat, warum die Burger
auf den Bildern besser aussehen, als sie in echt aussehen, dass die tatsächlich eine
offizielle Erklärung abgegeben haben dazu, warum das so ist, und zwar sagt McDonalds,
das muss so sein, weil die Burger auf den Bildern darauf optimiert sind, dass der Kunde
erkennen kann, was für Zutaten und, ja Ingredients sind Zutaten, was für Zutaten und zubereitet
und wieder zubereitet wird der Burger, deswegen sind die Bilder so wie die Bilder sind und
in echt sehen die Burger anders aus, weil sie dort geschmacksoptimiert sind.
Das sagt McDonalds, die sagen, die Bilder sind, dass der Kunde sich ein besseres Bild
über das Produkt machen kann, was drauf ist und die echten Burger sehen anders aus, weil
sie geschmacksoptimiert sind.
Könnt ihr nachgucken, das haben die wirklich erzählt, das ist, das ist Big Brain, Alter.
Hier, guck mal mal das Bild, this is not real, a day in the life of software first edition,
hier, guck mal was er dazu zu sagen hat, das hab ich glaube ich schonmal geguckt.
Leise, hä, ach das liegt daran, weil ich hier leiser gemacht hab, that's ok, ne.
brow,
Und ich denke, dass sie sich fast an die Hoffnungen und Träume der Menschen bewegen, wie es ist, einen Softwarejob zu bekommen.
Warum ich diese Videos mache, ist, weil ich einfach etwas Realismus hinzugeben und darüber reden möchte,
was wirklich bei der Arbeit passiert und was man in diesen Videos nicht sieht.
In manchen von diesen Videos gibt es fast mehr Essen im Video, als es bei der Arbeit gibt.
Ja.
Ach so, bevor wir weiterkommen, es hat vorhin irgendjemand gefragt, wie das bei mir aussieht mit Überstunden oder so.
Ich finde es jetzt gerade nicht.
Hier kannst du eigentlich pünktlich aus dem Büro gehen oder musst du häufig länger arbeiten.
Ich gehe so gut wie immer pünktlich aus dem Büro, es sei denn, es ist irgendwie eine Veranstaltung, wo man das aber meistens vorher schon weiß.
Ich hau immer exakt um 15.30 Uhr ab. Immer. Freitags vielleicht auch schon ein bisschen früher. Immer.
Ich bin 7 Uhr irgendwie so in dem Dreh da und dann hau ich immer Punkt 15.30, fällt der Hammer.
So 7 bis 15.30. So in dem Dreh. Plus Minus paar Minuten. Aber spätestens 15.30 fällt bei mir der Hammer, weil ich muss ja noch mit dem Zug heimfahren.
Da ist Schluss. Bam. 15.30 ist vorbei.
Dann laufe ich zum Südbahnhof in Frankfurt. Ich mache es ja morgens so.
Also ich könnte eigentlich locker eine Stunde länger auf der Arbeit sein und mehr Stunden machen oder früher heimgehen.
Ich laufe morgens eine halbe Stunde, also ich steige hier extra am anderen Bahnhof aus.
Ich laufe morgens eine halbe Stunde dann zur Arbeit und ich laufe mittags eine halbe Stunde von der Arbeit zum Bahnhof.
Einfach, dass man ein bisschen Bewegung hat. Weil ansonsten so viel mit Bewegung ist da halt nicht bei dem, was ich mache.
Warum bist du kein Fan davon, dich für die Firma einzusetzen und Karriere zu machen? Das ist eine persönliche Einstellungssache.
Ich habe da nichts dagegen, wenn jetzt irgendjemand sagt, er möchte irgendwie den Hardcore-Karriere-Grind oder so machen.
Das kann jeder machen, jeder machen wie er will. Aber ich denke, man sollte das erstmal grundsätzlich, bevor man sich dafür irgendwie entscheidet,
man sollte das erstmal grundsätzlich realistisch sehen. Man ist nicht irgendwo auf der Arbeit, weil die einen so mögen, bzw. man die selbst so sehr mögen muss.
Die meisten Unternehmen sind natürlich da ganz scharf drauf, quasi die Leute so ein bisschen zu brainwaschen,
so nach dem Motto, dass sie die geilsten, besten und sonstwas auf der Welt sind.
Es ist auch nicht verkehrt, weil man sich irgendwie mit seinem Arbeitgeber identifizieren kann.
Es ist aber, sag mal so, zum Arbeiten und zum Spaß an der Arbeit haben nicht unbedingt erforderlich, dass man die Firma an sich wahnsinnig geil findet.
Dazu kommt, warum ich keinen Bock auf Karriere-Stels habe, weil ich der Meinung bin, es gibt wichtigeres, was man machen kann als Arbeiten.
Und in der Regel, wenn du Karriere-Stels machen willst, das erste, was natürlich wichtig ist, ist, dass du viele Leute, die wichtig sind, kennst
und dementsprechend auf den üblichen Veranstaltungen, wo man sowas machen kann, da ein bisschen rumhängt.
Also Weihnachtsfeier skippen, wie ich das mache, ist schonmal nix. Sommerfest, Ostergeschiss skippen, wie ich das mache, ist schonmal nix.
Generell ist es auch ganz gut, wenn man den Chef hat, der die Sachen gut verkauft. Das hilft auch schonmal.
Und natürlich, das Wichtigste ist, es interessiert sich keiner dafür, ob man, oder kaum einer, kaum einer außer mehrere Stufen drüber,
ob man das macht, ob man das gut macht und richtig macht, was man immer macht.
Das interessiert eigentlich kaum einen. Wo man punkten kann, wenn man den Karriere-Kriant machen will, ist, vor allem in der IT geht das ganz gut,
wenn man, angenommen man dreht den ganzen Tag Däumchen, aber dann hat der Chef vom Chef vom Chef irgendwie eine, wie nennt man es so schön,
eine Herzensangelegenheit, nennen sie das bei uns immer. Und ihr habt quasi einen halben Monat Däumchen gedreht,
aber sobald ihr mitkriegt, dass der Chef vom Chef vom Chef, also der Oberchef, dass der irgendwas braucht,
und ihr geht dann voll drauf ab und macht das in 30 Minuten, das ist richtig nice und funktioniert, dann seid ihr der absolute Held.
Und das find ich dann geil, dass du jetzt irgendwie ansonsten quasi 340 Tage im Jahr die Sache so machst, dass es funktioniert.
Das juckt keinen. Das sind die Sachen, die gesehen werden. Und ehrlich gesagt habe ich auf so Geschiss nicht, sondern nicht viel Bock.
Es gibt ja auch, sagen wir mal, es gibt ja grundsätzlich zwei Varianten, wo jetzt auch immer mehr Unternehmen mittlerweile drauf kommen.
Und zwar, dass, also früher war es ja so, du konntest quasi, so dieser klassische Karriere-Karrieregeschichte war,
der erste ist natürlich, dass man viele Leute kennt und zweitens, dass man irgendwie irgendwelche Organisations-Management-Funktionen ausübt.
Das war früher so der einzige Karriereweg, den es so richtig gegeben hat.
Das Problem war natürlich nur, dass viele Leute, die sich für Technik interessieren, dass die absolut keinen Bock haben auf irgendwelche Personalverantwortung,
auf irgendwelche Führungsgeschichten, auf irgendwelche Management-Organisationskram, da haben die keinen Bock drauf.
Und deswegen kommen jetzt immer mehr Unternehmen glücklicherweise auf den Trichter, dass es nicht verkehrt ist, wenn man auch Leuten,
die sich für Technik interessiert, Optionen bietet. Und das ist was, da habe ich überhaupt nichts dagegen.
Das würde ich auch nicht, würde ich auch machen, wenn es da eine passende Position gäbe,
beziehungsweise ich den Arbeitsaufwand reinstecken wollte, den es da gibt.
Aber aktuell komme ich ja eh schon hinten und vorne nicht hin. Und außerdem bin ich der Meinung,
das muss aber jeder selbst sehen für sich, dass man nicht unbedingt nur lebt, um zu arbeiten.
Also sprich, man muss sich halt überlegen, was dann wichtig ist.
Wenn man sagt, ja, ich will hier irgendwie in irgendeiner Firma vorwärts kommen, was auch immer das für einen heißt,
kann ja jeder machen wie er will. Aber ich will ehrlich gesagt pünktlich heimgehen und eine Runde YouTube-Videos machen
und eine Runde, keine Ahnung, Overwatch, Borderlands oder sonst was spielen.
So, und das alles in Kombination kannst du halt nicht machen. Okay, es geht nicht alles, es geht nicht alles gleichzeitig.
Ja, im Vertrieb ist das anders, ja klar, das kann ich mir gut vorstellen.
Mein Chef meint, dass wir als was Mitarbeiter gleichzeitig für die Firma aufbringen müssen.
Ne, das einzige, was du machst, musst du nicht. Das einzige, was du machen musst, was übrigens oftmals vergessen wird,
was beide Seiten machen müssen, das einzige, was du machen musst ist,
und was die Firma auch machen muss, in der du arbeitest, ist das Erfüllen, was im Arbeitsvertrag drin steht.
Wenn da drin steht, 40 Stunden, dann steht da nicht, man kann nicht einfach sagen so nach dem Motto,
ja, das haben wir unterschrieben, das juckt mich nicht, das gilt für beide Seiten.
Was du da unterschrieben hast, musst du machen und was da drin steht, müssen die anderen auch machen.
Das ist das einzige, was du machen musst. Was dein Chef dazu denkt, wenn du den Chef hast,
der irgendwie der Meinung ist, er muss 70 Stunden die Woche arbeiten,
dann kann er das gerne denken, aber das muss man nicht machen.
Also ich würde das auch nicht machen. Und glücklicherweise ist es bei uns auch nicht so.
Wartet mal, ich will mal was trinken.
Glücklicherweise ist es bei uns auch nicht so. Die gucken da eigentlich schon ganz gut drauf,
dass du nicht zu viele Überstotten hast. Weil es ist ja sogar erwiesen mittlerweile,
dass Leute, die ausgeglichen sind, die da Spaß an der Sache haben, die nicht so sehr gestresst sind,
dass die bessere Arbeit abliefern. Und das ist ja auch eine Sache, die ist eigentlich ganz logisch.
Also ich spreche jetzt mal für Leute, die, sagen wir mal, was programmieren oder was administrieren
oder sich um IT-Architektur kümmern oder so, so grob in diesem Bereich,
muss man sagen, zum größten Teil hat es schon eine gewisse Portion Kreativität, die dabei ist.
Da ist schon eine gewisse Portion Kreativität dabei. Es ist zwar unabhängig davon, was man genau macht.
Also wenn einer sagt, dass das Programmieren oder Entwickeln gleich Code eintippen ist, ist Schwachsinn.
Das hat damit überhaupt nichts zu tun. Und deswegen ist halt auch die Sache so, wenn man gestresst ist,
da kann man nicht kreativ sein. Das ist eine Kombination, die passt nicht zusammen.
Wenn du gestresst bist, dann bist du quasi im Fluchtmodus sozusagen. Du willst weg.
Und wenn man weg will, ist man nicht kreativ. Das beißt sich.
Also wenn jemand mal vor einem Hund weggerannt ist, zum Beispiel, dann ist man ziemlich unter Stress.
Und ich glaube, keiner ist, während er mal vor einem Hund weggerannt ist,
hat sich dann zwischendrin überlegt, der Sinn des Lebens. Guckt euch mal diesen Baum hier an.
Das ist keiner. Wenn du wegrennst, wenn du unter Stress bist, dann rennst du
und machst dir da keine großartigen anderen Gedanken drunter. Bruder muss los.
Und deswegen funktioniert das nicht. Deswegen funktionieren generell Sachen, wo man kreativ sein muss
und Sachen, wo man sich konzentrieren muss oder fokussiert sein muss, geht nicht.
Konzentriert sein auf alles außer abhauen geht unter Stress, unter irgendwelchen Adrenalineinfluss geht nicht.
Das ist auch so eine Sache. Du hast ja auch in anderen Berufen...
Bist du schon mal vor einem Hund weggegangen? Ja, bin ich schon. Im Urlaub in Portugal war das, glaube ich.
Da rennen viele Hunde frei rum und der eine war halt der Meinung, er muss jetzt mal hinter ein paar Leuten herrennen.
Und meine Mutter hat dann damals gesagt, so nach dem Motto, bleib stehen, da tut nichts.
Wenn du wegrennst, flippt da noch mehr aus. Und ich bin halt gerannt, wie sonst was, weil das Ding sah halt übelst gefährlich aus.
Und der Witz ist, ich bin weggerannt und er hat dann jemand anderes gebissen.
Von wegen, wäre ich stehengeblieben, wäre ich stehengeblieben, wäre keine gute Idee gewesen.
Richtig, richtig knackt.
Das ist in anderen Berufen ja auch so.
Wenn ich mir zum Beispiel angucke, dass es Ärzte gibt, die dann auch zweistellige Schichtdinger machen am Stück
und dann quasi am Ende nochmal irgendetwas operieren sollen oder so.
Wie soll man ruhig und fokussiert das machen, nachdem man quasi gestresst ist?
Das kann doch eigentlich gar nicht richtig funktionieren.
Und es kommt nicht von ungefähr, dass in Berufen, wo man sich konzentrieren muss
oder auch in Entwicklungen und Forschungen und Science Geschichten,
dass da immer mehr Leute sich irgendwelche Beruhigungsmittel, Schrägstrich, Gehirn,
wie nennt man solche Mittel, wo man sich besser fokussieren kann oder auch irgendwelche Pro-Gamer,
dass die sich irgendwelche Sachen reinhauen, wo sie einfach länger am Stück fokussiert denken können.
Das ist halt das Problem, wenn du ein Umfeld hast, was eigentlich kreativitätsfokussierungsmäßig feindlich ist
und es wird trotzdem verlangt, dass du dich immer mehr konzentrierst.
Aber das kann ja nicht funktionieren.
Nee, nicht Ritalin. Die nehmen den Krams, die auch ganzen ADHS-Leute kriegen.
Es gab doch mal vor einer Weile diesen Skandal von vor drei, vier Jahren,
der immer gesagt hat, dass die ganzen CSGO-Pros vor einem Turnier sich alles Zeugs einschmeißen,
dass die halt in CS besser fünf Minuten auf eine Ecke fokussiert gucken können,
ob sich da ein Pixel verändert.
Das ist Ritalin, ja, kann sein.
Der I am Bumser, ach nee, ich hab mich verlesen.
Nicht I am Bumser, Lai Bumster.
I am Bumser wäre natürlich auch nicht verkehrt gelesen.
Sagt, in der aktuellen Firma haben wir eine 35-Stunden-Woche.
Leider wird auf jeden einzelnen so viel draufgepackt, dass alle komplett überlastet sind.
Nachher wird aber verbreitet, dass wir aufpassen sollen.
Ja, das ist so ein typischer Fall von, auf der einen Seite wird das erzählt und dann das andere gemacht.
Das hast du bei jedem Laden, genauso wie jeder Laden erzählt,
dass sie die geilsten in irgendeinem Bereich sind.
Die Sache ist nur die, oder es ist schwierig.
Also man kann jetzt nicht pauschal sagen, so nach dem Motto, ey, kann man nicht mitmachen.
Weil ich weiß, es ist prinzipiell schwierig, oder es kann schwierig sein,
je nachdem, wie man so ist, bei gewissen Sachen nicht mitzumachen,
die quasi allgemein akzeptiert sind dort, wo man ist.
Das ist ein bisschen schwierig.
Und eigentlich kann man da auch wenig dagegen machen, weil du kannst dich natürlich aufregen.
Ja, super, dann sagen sie hier, du bist kein Teamplayer oder irgendwie sowas.
Es ist schwierig, es ist schwierig.
Also eigentlich müssten das die Firma selbst irgendwie checken.
Aber es ist tatsächlich sehr widersprüchlich zu sagen,
ihr habt 35 Stunden Woche, achtet auf gesunde Mischungen aus Arbeit und Freizeit
und dann musst du so viel arbeiten, was unbedingt fertig werden muss,
wo dir die Leute auf den Sack gehen und du kommst in 35 Stunden nicht hin.
Das ist ein Problem, das ist aber ein organisatorisches Problem von dem jeweiligen Laden.
Das ist schwierig, ja.
Ich verlasse die Firma übrigens, ja, das ist eine gute Idee.
Das ist im Prinzip auch eines der wenigen Sachen, die man tatsächlich machen kann.
Das ist so blöd, wie es klingt, weil die meisten Läden tun sich unglaublich schwer damit,
grundlegende Sachen zu ändern.
Das ist sehr eingefahren, genauso wie es eingefahren ist bei mir,
wie ich hier mein Zeug angeordnet habe oder sonst was,
sind Abläufe in Unternehmen unglaublich eingefahren.
Vor allem, wenn es die schon seit einer Weile gibt.
Das ist sehr eingefahren und was halt viele Unternehmen dann gerne machen ist,
die holen sich vielleicht irgendwelche Beratungstypen oder irgendwelche Leute,
Coaches oder sonst was, die erklären ihnen, dass das eigentlich nicht gut ist,
wie das läuft, so wie dies halt gemacht wird, weil die Sachen so eingefahren sind.
Und dann wird dann groß verkündet, so nach dem Motto, das ändern wir jetzt.
Und dann gibt es dann auch zig Veranstaltungen zu, so nach dem Motto,
da war ja hier unsere neue Vision und das wird dann verkündet.
Und danach war es das.
Die neue Vision wird verkündet und fertig.
Und es ändert sich nichts.
Und es gibt Läden, da habe ich letztens auch einen schönen Vortrag
von einem Professor zugesehen auf YouTube.
Es gibt halt Firmen oder Unternehmen, die machen das halt regelmäßig,
so alle paar Monate.
Und da hat er gesagt, die Leute kapieren das mit der Zeit
und machen dann einfach Folgendes.
Wenn es heißt, es gibt jetzt neue Änderungen, die ultra wichtig sind
und neue Visionen, dann gehen die einfach 2-3 Wochen in Deckung,
äußern sich nicht dazu, rühren sich nicht, machen nichts,
weil sie wissen, danach kommt schon wieder was Neues.
Also ich weiß nicht mal, wie er das genannt hat, irgendwie Pendelinnovation
oder irgendwie so, also quasi, es kommt was Neues.
Du weißt im Prinzip, dass es nicht länger als 3 Wochen Bestand haben wird.
Und was die Leute machen, ist so nach dem Motto,
wow, ich weiche das Sache mal aus, weil ich weiß, wenn ich das Sache 3 Wochen ausgewichen bin,
da kommt eh schon wieder was Neues.
Also da kann man auch schon in viele Fallen tappen.
40 Stunden Woche ist für euch zu viel.
Kommt auf die einzelne Person an.
Also ich mittlerweile, muss ich sagen, ich persönlich finde,
dass 40 Stunden die Woche zu viel sind.
Ich arbeite ja auch nur noch 4 Tage die Woche.
Also sprich 4 x irgendwie 7,7 oder so ist das glaube ich bei uns irgendwie so in dem Dreh.
Wie viel habe ich eigentlich hier?
4 x 7,7.
Ah, 30 ungefähr.
30-31 Stunden habe ich so ungefähr.
In der Woche.
Und ich muss euch ehrlich sagen, ich habe keine Ahnung mehr,
wie ich das überhaupt hingekriegt habe, 5 Tage die Woche zuzuarbeiten.
Wie viel Geld verdienst du?
Ich weiß es selber nicht genau.
Das ist jetzt kein Witz.
Ich weiß es nicht.
Also spätestens seit ich seit ein paar Jahren 4 Tage die Woche arbeite,
ich habe das noch nie jetzt ausgerechnet, keine Ahnung.
Ich habe letztens mal so grob überschlagen, weil ich gesagt habe,
ich muss meinem Chef mal wieder auf den Sack gehen, dass ich mehr Kohle kriege.
Nicht, weil ich unbedingt mehr Kohle bräuchte, sondern weil ich der Meinung bin,
dass ich, ich meine, auch durch diese YouTube-Geschichte, weil ich halt mittlerweile,
wir eigentlich bei den, wisst ihr, wenn man irgendwann mal genug Kohle hat,
wenn man jetzt nicht jemand ist, der gerne sich irgendwie einen Rolex kaufen will
oder einen Porsche oder so, wenn du irgendwann mal genug Kohle hast,
dass du dir eigentlich ohne die Sachen zweimal rumzudrehen, dir immer die Sachen holen kannst,
wenn es jetzt halt nicht gerade ein neues fettes Auto in dein Haus oder sonst was ist,
wenn du dir so die Standardsachen immer holen kannst, wenn du sie haben willst,
dann machst du dir da weniger Gedanken drum.
Und deswegen weiß ich gar nicht, wie es ist.
Es ist jetzt aber nicht übertrieben viel oder so.
Ich denke, es ist für Frankfurter Verhältnisse ganz okay.
Aber ich weiß es, ich weiß schlicht und keimlich nicht.
Zumindest, ich habe letztens mal so ein bisschen grob überschlagen,
aber das ist auch schon wieder ein Jahr her, weil ich am Chef mal wieder auf den Keks gehen wollte,
dass ich mal wieder langsam ein bisschen mehr Kohle kriege, was vor allem daran liegt,
weil ich mir die letzten Jahre überhaupt gar nichts in dieser Richtung irgendwie unternommen habe.
Ich habe im Prinzip die Leute in Ruhe gelassen und ich bin so was genervt.
Jetzt wird es mal wieder Zeit. Ab und zu muss das sein.
Und außerdem mache ich auch genug Dinge, die aus meiner Sicht auch der Firma was bringen.
Und von Weihnachtsfeiern, Sommerfesten und irgendwie warmen Worten hat man ja im Prinzip auch nichts.
Und es passt auch nicht zusammen.
Und das ist eine Sache, wo ich denke, was viele Unternehmen auch machen ist,
da wird jedes Jahr vor allem welche, die an der Börse sind
oder aber die anderweitig irgendwie gut dastehen müssen finanztechnisch.
Die erzählen quasi jedes Jahr, dass das vergangene Jahr ein ganz tolles Jahr gewesen ist.
Nach dem Motto, wir haben jetzt wieder einen neuen Rekord erreicht im Bereich XY.
Wir haben jetzt wieder eine neue Auszeichnung gewonnen. Blablabla.
Und eine Sache, die ich da immer nicht verstehe ist, wie passt das zusammen?
Ich habe das von ein paar Kollegen mitgekriegt.
Die sind zu ihrem Chef gegangen und haben gesagt, wie sieht es denn mal aus? Mehr Kohle.
Und da muss der eine wohl wortwörtlich gesagt haben, weil er sich rausreden wollte.
Nee, also da sind mir die Hände gebunden.
Wo ich mir auch gedacht habe, alter, wenn an dieser Position so blöde Ausreden kommen.
Also der Witz ist ja, man kann nicht fünf Jahre in Folge immer neue Rekorde und Beste und sonst was verkünden.
So nach dem Motto, wir sind die Geilsten, wir sind noch geiler, noch geiler als geil.
Die oberultrageilsten und jetzt worldwide die Geilsten.
Und dann sagen so nach dem Motto, okay, also wir verdienen jedes Jahr mehr Geld,
wir machen jedes Jahr mehr Gewinn, wir machen jedes Jahr mehr Umsatz, wir machen jedes Jahr zig neue Leute dazu.
Wir haben jedes Jahr das, wir haben jedes Jahr weniger Konkurrenz.
Aber Moment, also wenn einer, der daran beteiligt ist, sagt, er möchte auch davon irgendwie was abmachen.
Nee, dann sind mir die Hände gebunden. Ja, das ist natürlich Blödsinn.
Und das ist einfach so ein, wo ich mir denke, das passt irgendwie nicht so ganz zusammen.
Deswegen bin ich auch ganz froh, dass ich mich an irgendwelchem großartigen Karrierecry nicht beteilige.
Sondern ich mach das, was mir Spaß macht und ansonsten ist mein Hauptlebensinhalt nicht arbeiten gehen.
So ist jede Firma, ja. Aber man muss das denen auch ab und zu mal aus Brot schmieren, dass es,
zumindest aus meiner Sicht oder aus der Sicht der Leute, dass es nicht zusammenpasst.
Weil es ist bei vielen Sachen so, ich meine, das ändern wird sich da nichts dran.
Aber es gibt teilweise ganz merkwürdige Reaktionen drauf, wenn man die Leute mal mit sowas konfrontiert.
Wenn man einfach nur so blöd fragt, wie kann das oder wie passt das eigentlich zusammen?
Passt das eigentlich zusammen? Dann geraten die Leute zumindest mal ein bisschen in Erklärungsnot.
Es kommt aber auch ein bisschen auf den Laden an.
Arbeitest du nach Tarifvertrag, hat jemand gefragt? Ja, mache ich.
Also das setzt sich zusammen aus Tarifvertrag plus Bonus.
Also im Prinzip ist es ja so, was da im Tarifvertrag drinne steht, ist das Mindeste,
was dir bezahlt werden muss auf dieser Position.
Das heißt nicht, dass dir nicht mehr bezahlt werden darf.
Und ja, wir können uns den aktuellen Tarifvertrag mal angucken, wenn ihr wollt.
Da kann man zumindest so grob erkennen, was ich verdiene an Kohle.
Aber wie gesagt, da kommt noch Zeug drauf.
Ich bin mir aber auch gar nicht sicher, in welchem Tarifvertrag wir genau sind.
Ich glaube, wir sind im Tarifvertrag für Bank und Versicherung.
Metall, nein, nein. Wir sind in...
Ich muss mal kurz gucken.
Ich werde ihn, ich werde ihn, oder?
Dann seht ihr mal, wie geil ich mich damit auskenne.
UV-Gewerkschaften, ne, ne, ne. Wenn ich die, wenn ich die... auch nicht.
Finanzleistung, vielleicht.
Wir sind nicht bei Verdi, das weiß ich. Gibt's denn da noch alles so?
Ist die Musik eigentlich gerade zu leise?
Mist, wie heißt denn der Laden, wo wir...
Ich arbeite zwar bei einer Bank, aber die machen das ja taktisch geschickt.
Man arbeitet ja nicht, man ist ja nicht direkt bei dieser Bank angestellt,
sondern bei irgendeinem Subding, was dann da die IT-Dienstleistung für die Bank macht.
Das ist wahrscheinlich steuerlich künstiger.
Versicherung? Ich such mal noch Versicherung.
Das, das hier, ja, das sind die, glaube ich.
Ja, ich glaube, ich glaube, die sind dafür zuständig bei uns.
Jetzt ist die Musik zu laut?
Okay, das kann sich nicht entscheiden, irgendwie.
So, also ich glaube, das ist der Versichere als Arbeitgeber.
So, okay. Wo sind jetzt die Tarifverträge hier? Tarifverhandlungen, Tarifverträge?
Oh, die ganzen Subs habe ich ja voll vergessen.
Flix.at, Twitch Prime, Dankeschön, zwei Monate.
Ich muss mal nachgucken, ich habe ganz vergessen,
ganz vergessen, die ganzen Subscribers heute zu erwähnen.
Und zwar, wen haben wir denn da alles?
Wir haben, der brauner Marock ist am Start, Twitch Prime.
Und dann haben wir Daniel Lull, SilentPain und Flex.at.
Dankeschön, alle für die Subs.
SilentPain sogar vier Monate in Folge.
Huge, big brain. IQ ist wieder steil hoch hier im Chat.
So, okay. Wo ist jetzt hier, wo ist jetzt hier der Gehaltstarifvertrag?
Das müsste der eigentlich sein.
Okay, also, ist der das? Also ich bin Gehaltsgruppe.
Eins davon bin ich.
Seht ihr mal, ich habe echt keinen Plan, so richtig, was ich verdiene.
Ich bin eins davon. Und vor allem, ich bin auf jeden Fall ab 14.
Ja, 14 links. Eins davon bin ich.
Wir können einfach mal beides ausrechnen, ich habe keine Ahnung.
Da ist, wie gesagt, Bonus und so kommt ja alles noch dabei,
falls man einen bekommt.
Also sprich, das, was man hier sieht, ist wirklich nur das Mindeste,
was einem bezahlt werden muss, wenn quasi der jeweilige Arbeitgeber
da in diesen Tarifvertrag unterschrieben hat
und ihr in dieser passenden Gehaltsgruppe seid.
Das ist das Mindeste, was, und den Berufsjahr, das ist das Mindeste,
was, das heißt nicht, dass ihr nicht mehr bekommen könnt,
beziehungsweise es heißt auch nicht, dass ihr einfach in eine andere
Gehaltsgruppe eingruppiert werden könnt oder so.
So, also, was, was?
Gültig ab, okay. Nehmen wir jetzt mal, nehmen wir mal das hier.
Das ist, das ist im Monat.
What, kann man das nicht copy and paste?
Hallo, copy and paste?
Ja, 8880 mal 14, wir kriegen 14 Jahresgehälter.
Also sind wir bei 54.320.
Das ist das, das ist so die basic Sache, die quasi bezahlt wird
rein nach dem Tarifvertrag.
Muss jetzt noch mal gucken, ob das auch stimmt, was ich hier erzähle.
Was ist das? Gültig ab.
Ja, was bei uns auch geil ist, wir kriegen das, wir kriegen die
komplette Fahrkarte mittlerweile günstiger.
Nicht komplett bezahlt, aber günstiger.
Verantwortungszulagen gibt es dann noch.
Also ich kann es euch nicht genau sagen, weil bei mir kommt noch
ein bisschen was obendrauf und da weiß ich auch, ich hab echt keine Ahnung.
Also gehen wir mal von aus, dass es irgendwie, was haben wir gesagt,
irgendwie 55.000 über den Daumen gepeilt waren das.
Und davon ziehen wir jetzt irgendwie noch mal 55.000.
Wie viel müssen wir dann noch mal abziehen?
20% oder so?
Stimmt das, was ich da mache?
Also müsste ich das, das mal 14 kriegen.
Moment.
Passt, passt.
Normale Null hinten dran.
Also müsste ich im Jahr mindestens 44 mal 0,8.
Ja, ist eigentlich viel, viel sinnvoller.
Kommt aber halt aufs Gleiche raus.
Also müsste ich mindestens im Jahr das hier kriegen bei 4 Tagen die Woche
laut Tarifvertrag.
Aber ich gehe davon aus, das rechnet sich nicht exakt so.
Aber so ungefähr so eine Hausnummer ist das.
So über den Daumen gepeilt kann man das glaube ich jetzt mal ganz gut einschätzen.
Wahrscheinlich Bonus.
Ne, also es gibt, je nachdem was ansteht, gibt es so, wie nennt man das,
noch mal zusätzlich quasi so, keine Ahnung wie heißt denn das irgendwie.
Man hat sich besonders hervorgetan, Bonus irgendwie.
Also irgendwie die, man hat hier so besonders tolle Sachen abgeschlossen
oder Prämie, Prämie, ja genau, das klingt gut.
Das gibt es.
Aber ich weiß, dass bei mir im Vertrag ist halt so eine extra Sektion,
die nicht abhängig ist von irgendwelchen Projekten oder sonst was.
Das kommt einfach immer noch mal, noch mal dazu.
Deswegen, das ist das Mindeste, was man bezahlt kriegen muss,
wenn der Arbeitgeber in diesem Tarifvertrag drin ist,
wenn man diese Berufserfahrung hat plus halt in dieser Gehaltsgruppe einsortiert ist.
Das ist jetzt natürlich, wenn man jetzt mal die YouTube-Geschichten
und irgendwelche Sellout-Geschichten und auch hier Subscriber-Geschichten,
wenn man das mal außen vor lässt, ist das, was wollte ich jetzt sagen,
das ist natürlich weit davon entfernt, was manche andere hier
sich die Rolex gönnen können irgendwie im Monat oder so.
Aber das bewegt sich auch ohne alle anderen Einnahmen,
die es noch irgendwie dazu gibt.
So in dem Bereich, wo man halt sagen kann, okay,
eigentlich interessiert es einen nicht mehr so wirklich,
wie viel es jetzt hinter dem Komma genau ist,
sondern man kommt damit wirklich gut aus.
Also wenn ich der Meinung bin, ey, ich brauche irgendwie keine Ahnung,
eine Klimaanlage, kann ich mir eine Klimaanlage kaufen.
Oder wenn ich, wenn ich irgendwie sage, hier,
ich hätte gern mein Klo mit Spülung, kann ich mir das auch kaufen.
Ich meine, ich kann mir davon jetzt natürlich nicht irgendwie drei Häuser kaufen oder so.
Aber ich will mir auch keine drei Häuser kaufen.
Ich habe ein Haus, das reicht.
Genug, genug mit Arbeitssachen.
Wie hast du jetzt eigentlich deine aktuelle Katze genannt?
Gar nicht. Die heißt schon seit Anfang an so hier. Guck.
Wo ist sie? Ah.
Eigentlich heißt sie Chico, aber Chico, Chico klingt irgendwie nicht so weiblich.
Deswegen sage ich mal Chica oder Chico, eins von beiden.
Und die reagiert da auch voll drauf.
Ich dachte, die ist, nein, die nicht.
Das ist schon die dritte.
Ich hatte ja nicht so viel Glück mit den, mit Katz FPS.
Das ist jetzt innerhalb von ein paar Jahren schon die dritte.
Die erste, die hier.
Das hier war die erste, die hatte ich vom Nachbar.
Der wohnt ja da nicht mehr.
Also der ist ja, was heißt der wohnt da nicht mehr, der ist hinüber.
Und die hat eines Tages dort im Hof gestanden, hat rumgemautzt.
Und da habe ich ihr was zu essen gegeben.
Und seitdem hat sie sich gedacht, okay, dann ziehe ich einfach nebenan ein.
Die war aber halt auch schon alt, die war 14 oder so.
Ihr kennt ja vielleicht noch ein paar Videos, die war ja ein paar Videos dabei.
Die war aber halt schon relativ alt, die hat dann auch Probleme gehabt.
So und danach hat ich Barbie, die heißt halt wirklich so und ich habe sie nicht so genannt.
Also die heißt, polnisch glaube ich, Barbie.
Ich hätte meine Katze nie Barbie genannt.
Die hatte ich nur, die hatte ich nur ein dreiviertel Jahr, halbes Jahr, dreiviertel Jahr.
Weil die war von Anfang an schon krank, das wusste man damals bloß nicht.
So und jetzt, jetzt habe ich Chico.
Aber die ist auch alt, die sind alle alt, die sind alle 10 plus.
Aber der geht es gut.
Das ist auch die erste reine Wohnungskatze.
Die könnten ja theoretisch bei uns zumindest in Hof und auch teilweise in Garten.
Wobei Garten eher nicht mehr so, da kommt die glaube ich nicht rein.
Aber die will nicht raus.
Die will nicht raus.
Die war immer Wohnung gewöhnt und die geht nicht raus.
Wenn ich die Haustür aufmache, wenn ich die Haustür aufmache, dann geht die immer hinter die Treppe und versteckt sich.
So nach dem Motto nicht, dass der mich rausschmeißt oder so.
Die will nicht raus.
Was die aber macht ist, die legt sich immer unten im Badezimmer, legt die sich aufs Fensterbrett oder halt da über dem Klo und guckt raus.
Und guckt dann immer zu, wie die Vögel draußen Zeug fressen.
Aber selbst wird die nie im Leben raus wollen.
Alte Rentnerin am Fenster, ja ist echt so.
Warum holst du dir keine jungen Katzen?
Weil ich denke, also erstens, da hat man mehrere Gründe.
Alte Katzen werden besonders schlecht vermittelt und alte Katzen leben jetzt halt auch irgendwie nicht mehr 15 Jahre oder so.
Deswegen ist es scheiße, wenn sie die letzten paar Jahre, natürlich kann die auch noch 10 Jahre leben, aber Katzen können auch 20 plus werden, das ist kein Problem.
Da irgendwie im Tierheim rumgammeln ist kacke.
Dazu kommt, dass alte Katzen eigentlich am wenigsten gern vermittelt werden, also viele Leute wollen keine alten Katzen.
Und dass man den Vorteil hat, wenn man sich eine alte Katze holt, man weiß, was man kriegt.
Das ist echt so, man weiß, was man kriegt.
Wenn du dich mit einer alten Katze verstehst und die sich mit dir versteht, das ist eigentlich das Wichtigere, dann kannst du davon ausgehen, die ist halt so.
Der musst du auch nichts mehr beibringen, du weißt, wenn man zusammenpasst, dann passt man zusammen, das passt.
Entwickelt dann auch nicht irgendwelche Macken oder so, die wissen auch alle, wie man schön kacken geht, richtig oder sowas.
Also ich finde alte Katzen, vor allem ein Vorteil von alten Katzen ist, die sind halt super entspannt.
Ich meine, Katzen pennen allgemein schon viel, aber alte Katzen, die pennen ja nur.
Was für eine Web-App läuft da bei dir? Das ist hier mein Tool, wo ich Sachen, Bilder auferlegen kann.
Hat deine Katze auch ein automatisiertes Klo? Nee, aber die hat zwei Stück.
Die hat unten unter der Treppe eins, wo man mit Dach drüber und oben bei mir in dieser Abstellküche hat die auch noch eins hinter der Tür stehen.
Die braucht das auch, die geht da regelmäßig auf alle hin, hin und zurück.
Bist du gesund so allgemein? Ja, ich bin gesund.
Und damit das so bleibt, laufe ja jetzt jeden Tag 2x30 Minuten am Tag.
Weil nichts ist eigentlich schädlicher, oder also eines der schädlichsten, die du überhaupt machen kannst, ist einfach den ganzen Tag sitzen.
Das ist die beschissenste Position überhaupt.
Deswegen habe ich mir auch daheim, also nicht nur daheim, sondern auch auf der Arbeit überall einen Stehschreibtisch.
Und versuche mich zumindest ein bisschen zu bewegen, was aber halt ehrlich gesagt nicht so einfach in den Ablauf passt.
Weil ich will ja, wenn ich von der Arbeit fertig bin, will ich ja eigentlich direkt daheim mein YouTube-Streaming und sonst was Zeug machen.
Die Stehschreibtische sind nice, ja. Sehr nice.
UI upscaling, das 2.
Das sieht ehrlich gesagt aus wie ein Schärfefilter von Photoshop, der es irgendwie nur fake-schärfer macht.
Oder? Ich meine, das sieht aus wie so ein Schärfefilter von Photoshop, der es so besonders crisp aussehen lässt, aber nicht wirklich viel mehr Details hier rauskriegt.
Aber ich meine, das sieht schon besser aus, kann man nichts sagen.
Bist du gesund zu allgemein? Ja, hatten wir gerade schon. Hatte eine Katze auch ein automatisiertes Klo.
Hättest du gerne eine Freundin? Ja und nein.
Meine letzten, das war nicht so erfolgreich.
Teilweise hat man das ja auch mitgekriegt.
Es gab ja Zeiten, da war ich echt nicht so gut drauf.
Ich habe ja auch ein paar Videos in den Zeiten gemacht. Ja und nein.
Das Weihnachtsgrill. Ja, aber das liegt an mir. Das ist genau wieder das richtige Beispiel dafür.
Das Problem, was ich da habe, ist, dass ich Leute an sich halt ultra anstrengend finde und ich überhaupt keine Motivation habe, was zwischenmenschliche Interaktion angeht.
Wenn jemand zu mir kommt und sagt irgendwas erzählt, dann rede ich mit denen. Ich sage nicht, Alter, piss dich oder so oder hau ab.
Aber wenn ich mich um das Fliegen sozialer Kontakte kümmern muss, dann mache ich das nicht.
Also wenn jetzt jemand sagt, ey Max, wollen wir mal hier XY machen oder so, dann denke ich mir immer, ne, Alter, keinen Bock.
Aber mach das dann vielleicht doch. Aber ich bin jemand, der von sich aus so gut wie nie auf die Idee kommt zu sagen, hier lass uns mal irgendwas machen oder so.
Deswegen ist das nicht so förderlich, ja.
Man muss halt auch ehrlich sagen, dass diese ganze Geschichte aus, sag mal, den ganzen Tag oder sag mal so Großteil arbeiten plus dann halt daheim irgendwelche Stream-Geschichten, YouTube-Geschichten oder irgendwelche anderen Sachen quasi vor Bildschirm zu machen, dass das schon in gewisser Weise dazu führt, dass man weniger mit anderen Leuten zu tun hat.
Aber auf der anderen Seite ist es glaube ich auch so, dass Leute, die eh schon keinen Bock haben oder wünsche ich mich mal zu zählen, ich habe schon öfters gesagt, dass ich eigentlich andere Leute überhaupt nicht mag, außer Q-Chat ausgenommen, dass die sich gerade solche Beschäftigungen und Berufe suchen.
Wenn du jemand bist, der eh schon keinen Bock auf Leute hat, dann wirst du dir wahrscheinlich einen Beruf suchen, der nicht viel mit Leuten zu tun hat, beziehungsweise wenn dann mit halbwegs gleichgesinnten Leuten und die halt auch sonst die passenden Hobbys dazu suchen, ja.
Und außerdem kommt noch dazu, dass das die letzten Wahlen überhaupt nicht punktiert hat, das hat nur dafür gesorgt, dass ich ultra schlecht drauf war und ja da irgendwie, wie soll ich sagen, ich viel zu viele Gedanken gemacht habe um irgendwelche Mädels und Gefühlslagen anderer Leute und das kriege ich halt nicht gescheit hin.
Anmachsprüche, da brauchst du ein USB-Kabel.
Weiß nicht, ob das so zieht.
Ich merke das auch, ich merke das auch immer, dass ich übelst unmotiviert bin, was sowas anbelangt, wenn, ich meine es ist heute eh schwierig, sag mal mal so, wenn du irgendwie im Zug sitzt auf dem Heimweg oder so, die Leute interagieren ja eh schon relativ wenig.
Was ich, wo viele drüber rumweinen, so nach dem Motto, oh nein, das gucken alle nur noch auf ihr Handy und so, ich finde das nicht schlecht, ich will eh nicht mit den Leuten interagieren, aber manchmal, ja, manchmal interagiert man ja doch, was weiß ich, wenn man in Frankfurt irgendwie rumläuft, irgendwas anguckt oder wenn man im Zug sitzt, weil manchmal interagiert man doch, doch mal irgendwie mit Leuten und manchmal hat man auch so das Gefühl, wenn man mit Leuten oder im Fall mit Mädels irgendwie zufälligerweise irgendwie ins Gespräch kommt,
dass man sich eigentlich doch irgendwie ganz gut versteht und dass man auch schon eine gewisse, wie soll man, wie nennt man es am besten, gewisse Chemie hat, die irgendwie passt, ja.
Und dann, ja, wäre es ja eigentlich, also jeder wahrscheinlich normale Mensch würde dann versuchen irgendwie die Sache weiter zu verfolgen, ja.
In welcher Art und Weise auch immer, was weiß ich, ob sie öfters hingeht oder was weiß ich, wie sie das und das findet, irgendwas, irgendwas in der Richtung, ja. Es geht ja gar nicht so sehr darum, ob es einen wirklich interessiert, sondern einfach nur, dass man ein bisschen Gesprächsstoff hat irgendwo.
Und das Problem an mir ist, wenn so ein Fall mal eintritt, dass man merkt, ey, man ist da irgendwie halbwegs auf einer Wellenlänge, dann sag ich dann, ah ja, war irgendwie so nach dem Motto, war cool, sich mal zu unterhalten und dann gehe ich heim.
So, steige ich wieder in den Zug und vermiss mich. Ohne irgendwas probiert zu haben oder sonst was, ich hab da so, mir fehlt da voll die Motivation zu, was zwischenmenschliche Interaktion angeht.
Ich hab voll die Abneigung dagegen, irgendwie mit Leuten zu interagieren, ne.
Du zwingst deine Freunde immer mal ins Stream zu gucken, ich weiß nicht, ob das die beste Idee ist.
Ja, übrigens, der Milchmann hat einen guten, guten Punkt gebracht, wenn man sich zusammen über die Bahn aufregt.
Ihr glaubt gar nicht, wie sehr die Leute auf einmal, wenn irgendwas im Zug nicht funktioniert, wie sehr die Leute auf einmal anfangen, sich miteinander zu reden und sich zuzustimmen und sich zu unterhalten und so.
Dann sind die Bahns wieder verkackt, die unterhalten sich dann auch am Anfang über die Bahn, dann über alles Mögliche.
Aber sobald der Zug wieder weiterfährt, siehst du so, siehst du jeden so, ach ja, okay, geht ja weiter. Handy gucken, auf einmal instant wieder Ruhe im Zug.
Pavel Omen, ja, das, das mach ich aber auch nicht.
Unternimmst du dann etwas mit Kollegen und Freunden, so ein paar Feierabendbier, ne, Feierabendbier, ich trinke kein Bier.
Ab und zu, aber, aber nur mit Leuten, wo ich mich echt gut verstehe.
Wie gesagt, mit dem Felix war ich ja ein paar Mal auf der Gamescom, das ist ja auch jemand, den ich von der Arbeit kenne, wir haben zusammen die Ausbildung gemacht damals.
Aber zum größten, zum größten Teil, ich hab auch nicht so wahnsinnig viele Freunde irgendwie, ne.
Also wo ich wirklich sagen würde, Leute, mit denen ich mich die lange Jahre gut verstehe, gibt's eigentlich nur den Friseur, vielleicht noch ein bisschen den Carsten an, mit dem hab ich in letzter Zeit wenig zu tun.
Gibt's eigentlich nur den Faria, ansonsten gehen mir alle anderen Leute mega auf den Sack.
Voll die Abneigung mit Menschen zu interagieren, interagiert aber gerade mit dran an Menschen, ja, das ist ja auch hier, ist ja auch, Q-Chat, da war's anderes.
Legt mal ein paar Mal hintereinander auf die Schallfläche neben dem Windows-Logo.
Was ist da?
Was soll da passieren?
Hä?
Hast du eigentlich Fangirls? Nee, nicht wirklich.
Ich hab ein paar weibliche Zuschauer, das weiß ich, aber ich hab generell wenige Hardcore-Hardcore-Fans allgemein, ich mein, wozu, finde ich.
Das liegt aber auch daran, weil die Leute, glaub ich, wissen, wenn ich das bescheuert finde.
Du musst dir einen Hund zulegen, dann reden nicht plötzlich alle Anwälte zutraulicher, ich will ja gar nicht angesprochen werden.
Ich will mal eine Ruhe.
Seht ihr, ich seh auch nicht so, dass ich gerne mit Leuten, es ist ja nicht so, dass ich nicht mit Leuten reden könnte, aber ich will ja nicht mit Leuten reden.
Wenn ich mit Leuten reden möchte, dann könnte ich das ja auch irgendwie versuchen, aber ich will ja gar nicht.
Erlebst du auch immer wieder, dass Leute in Gesprächen mit dir eigentlich gar nicht wirklich interagieren wollen?
Na ja, nachdem ich mit keinem interagiere, oder nachdem ich bin ja auch jemand, der mit keinem reden will,
deswegen rede ich eigentlich auch nur mit Leuten, wo man sich meistens schon kennt und weiß, dass man eigentlich ganz gut mit einer labern kann.
Wie ist dein Kontakt zu deinen Eltern oder Verwandten? Verwandten gar nicht.
Also ich weiß gar nicht, wo ich als Verwandte bin, nicht wirklich.
Meine Mutter wohnt ja hier, das ist ja das Haus, das wir vom Opa geerbt haben, und mein Vater wohnt irgendwo in...
Keine Ahnung, wie das Kaff heißt, aber mit meinem Vater habe ich nicht allzu viel zu tun, es sei denn, er braucht Geld.
Ich weiß, es klingt jetzt nach ein bisschen verkehrter Welt, aber so ist das da bei uns.
Also normalerweise ist es ja so, dass die Kinder zu ihren Eltern gehen, wenn sie Geld brauchen, bei uns ist das umgedreht.
Wenn der Geld braucht, kommt er zu mir.
Ja stell so, das ist nice.
Exclusive hat die Twitch Prime, danke schön.
Kannst du mal ein paar weibliche zu vermitteln? Ich wüsste nicht, wie ich das machen soll.
Welte ich bei Knudelsalat? Gibt es das noch?
Die Musik ist ein bisschen eintönt.
Ich dachte, früher habe ich es ja noch probiert, so zu sein, wie ich dachte, dass man sein muss.
Ich hatte so die krasse Gel-Schleim-Frisur damals, der Wahnsinn.
Und ich habe damals schon immer gemerkt, irgendwie liegt mir diese ganze soziale, zwischenmenschliche Komponente überhaupt nicht.
Und ich habe damals immer gedacht, warum sind die Leute so komisch?
Und irgendwann habe ich dann kapiert, dass die Leute gar nicht komisch sind, sondern dass ich irgendwie zu den meisten Leuten einfach kein Draht habe oder nicht passe.
Und das ist auch nicht schlimm, aber das braucht eine Weile, bis man quasi realisiert, dass das auch irgendwo dazugehört,
wenn man halt vielleicht in manchen Beziehungen nicht so ist, wie man sich so die Normen vorstellt oder wie man sich so vorstellt, wie es sein muss.
Weil viele Leute reden sich ja ein, dass sie anders sein müssten, als sie eigentlich sind,
weil sie denken, dass das irgendwie, keine Ahnung, gesellschaftlicher akzeptiert ist oder dass das irgendwie die Welt so will oder so.
Aber das dauert ein bisschen, aber irgendwann kommt man mal da drauf, eigentlich hat das überhaupt keinen Sinn,
wenn man das versucht so zu machen, wie man denkt, dass es sein müsste, ohne dass man das selbst will.
Nudels gibt es noch tatsächlich.
Kann dir Grindr empfehlen als Dating App?
Ich dachte, das ist überhaupt nicht mehr im Trend, dass man quasi die Sachen mit R, so Fiverr, Twitter, Flickr.
Ich dachte, das ist überhaupt nicht mehr im Trend.
Ich dachte, die mit R hinten dran ist gar nicht mehr im Trend, so.
Da habe ich irgendwelche Subs übersehen.
Wir haben übrigens noch gar nichts gemacht, was wir normalerweise im Aufwachstream machen.
Ein bisschen Witz.
Okay, was haben wir sonst noch zu bieten hier?
Using Worst Classes in Black Ops 1.
Ach nee, was ich angucken wollte, ist das hier.
Das habe ich nämlich heute Morgen gesehen.
Kona.
Das habe ich heute Morgen nämlich bei mir auf dem Tablet gesehen.
Das ist ein ehemaliger Microsoft-Mitarbeiter, der sich darüber auslässt, warum Windows 10 so viele Bugs hat.
Das wollte ich mir mal angucken, mal gucken, ob das funktioniert.
Funktionieren tut es ja nicht, wenn es viele Bugs hat.
Warum hast du eine englische Tastatur?
Habe ich nicht.
Ich habe eine englische Sprache und eine deutsche Tastatur.
Jetzt was trinken.
Ich glaube auch, ich bin der Einzige, der in der IT arbeitet, der keinen Kaffee trinkt.
Wir haben hier kostenlose Kaffeedings.
Das ist ja kein Kaffeeautomat.
Das sind so fette Maschinen, die irgendwie acht verschiedene Sorten Kaffee machen können.
Von Espresso zu normalem Kaffee zu irgendwelchem Lattezeugs und so.
Und das kostet bei uns ja nichts.
Und dementsprechend ist vor diesen Kaffeeautomaten, das bei uns immer übertrieben voll.
Und ich laufe da immer so vorbei, um ab und zu für meinen Tee die Tasse zu holen.
Und da denken sie also nämlich, ich will an den Kaffeeautomaten.
Da stehen die Leute, da bleibt stehen, den Kaffee trinke ich gar nicht.
Ich weiß nicht, warum alle so auf Kaffee stehen, kann ich nicht verstehen.
Tee größer Kaffee, ja.
Kommt da ein Switch ab und zu noch zum Einsatz?
Ja.
Jetzt wieder.
Ich hab mir jetzt links gekauft hier. Links Awakening für die Switch.
Die Musik ist zu laut.
Ja, das ist mal wieder, weil sich die nicht entscheiden können, wie laut ihre unterschiedliche Musik sein will.
Ich geh auch nicht in irgendwelche Geschäfte fällt mir gerade einer.
Das Einzige, wo ich manchmal in Geschäfte gehe ist, wenn man Lebensmittel kaufen muss.
Aber ansonsten, alles online kaufen.
Ich glaube, die meiste Interaktion und rocky sind immer online.
Ich gehe auch nicht in irgendwelche Geschäfte, fällt mir gerade einer.
Das einzige, wo ich manchmal in Geschäfte gehe, ist, wenn man Lebensmittel kaufen muss.
Aber ansonsten, alles online kaufen.
Ich glaube, die meiste Interaktion, zwischenmenschliche Interaktion,
die nicht mit Leuten auf der Arbeit ist, hatte ich mit meinem DHL- und Hermeszusteller in den letzten Jahren.
Du kaufst Tee online, ja?
Ja, war hier.
Ah, da kaufe ich Tee.
Was sich übelst eklig anhört, aber gut schmeckt, ist
ähm
was?
Ah, es gibt es nicht mehr.
Hier, kaufe ich mal.
Himmlische Zitrone, das ist nice. Davon habe ich ein paar Packen.
Also ich habe schon ein paar Packen gekauft, die sind echt nice.
Das finde ich bei uns gut.
Bei uns ist es auf der Arbeit nicht so.
Also zumindest mit den Leuten, wo ich da samarbeite.
Konkurrenz gibt es in dieser Form bei uns nicht.
Wir machen uns eher gemeinsam über andere Entwicklungen lustig.
Hast du mal Matcha getrunken? Du meinst dieses grüne, japanische Zeug, ja?
Geht so, nicht mein Fall.
Ist ja mittlerweile relativ im Trend, gibt es jetzt ja auch mittels Tee,
welche anderen Drinks und so, wo die das reinmachen. Ich finde das nicht so gut.
Wo ist denn das, was ich aktuell trinke? Ich glaube, das gibt es.
Lemon Twist ist auch nice.
Das schmeckt auch gut.
Kürkischer Apfelraum ist auch nice.
Süßer Drachenwitz, übertreiben sie es aber mit den Namen, oder?
Na ja gut, wir gucken uns das jetzt Video an.
Max, kannst du mal OBS Einstellungen erklären?
Was denn genau? Trinkst du Energy Drinks? Nee.
Was das angeht, lebe ich eigentlich relativ gesund.
Dafür ist das restliche Leben nicht so gesund.
Ich trinke keine Fanta Cola, kein Kaffee, keine Energy Drinks.
Ich trinke eigentlich nur Wasser und Tee.
Dafür ist das andere nicht so gesund.
Ich rauche auch nicht, ich trinke nichts.
Also wenig.
Sehr wenig, so 1-2 Mal im Jahr was.
Ich vertrage auch überhaupt nichts mehr.
Rauchen tue ich auch nicht.
Das einzige, was ich mache, ist, ich sitze zu viel vor dem Rechner.
OBS zum Streamen ist das Beste, was du machen kannst.
Zum Aufnehmen finde ich Shadowplay eigentlich recht angenehm.
Das ist eine Sache, ganz ehrlich, die würde ich sogar mal ausprobieren.
Aber das Problem ist, da gibt es ja bei uns ein paar.
Wenn ich da reingucke, in diese Bars, die es bei uns in Frankfurt im Bahnhof hat,
und ich da reingucke und sehe, was da für Leute sowohl da vorne sind als auch da drinnen sitzen,
dann frage ich mich, keine Ahnung, ob das noch in Frankfurt ist.
Da gehe ich nicht rein.
Ich glaube, da habe ich mich, als wir in der Türkei im Urlaub waren,
ich glaube, da habe ich mich irgendwo in der türkischen Innenstadt
heimischer gefühlt als im Shisha-Laden im Frankfurt-Bahnhof-Viertel.
Warst du mal im Irish Pub beim Bahnhof, Leer?
Aber ich weiß, wo du meinst.
Direkt an der Treppe, wo du quasi unten durchlaufen kannst vom Bahnhof.
Läuft Shadowplay mittlerweile ohne in GeForce Experience World?
Nein, leider nicht.
Das kann schon sein, ich gehe da ja gar nicht hin.
Das kann schon sein, ich kenne nur die, wo ich vorbeilaufe, bei uns in Frankfurt im Bahnhof-Viertel,
und die sehen nicht so aus, als will ich da rein.
Ganz ehrlich.
Und GeForce Experience ist der letzte Scheiß.
So, gucken wir uns mal, was eher zu sagen.
Warum hat Windows 10 so viele Bugs?
Erzählt uns ein Ex-Microsoft-Mitarbeiter.
Dann gucken wir mal.
Ein 8K!
What the fuck?
Ich wollte ihn mir schon immer in 8K angucken.
2K.
Kein Unterschied.
1440p, auch kein Unterschied.
1440p reicht.
Okay.
Also, hören wir uns das mal an, was er sagt.
Hey, what is up, guys?
Jerry here, aka Barnacles, coming at you with another Windows 10 video.
It's been a while.
We're going to talk about why Windows 10 quality has been such a rollercoaster ride.
Passt aufsteigen?
Ich denke schon.
That is right, I worked there for 15 years.
15 Jahre Microsoft, Alter.
Wow, guys.
Das ist cool.
Das finde ich richtig cool.
Das sollten wir auch machen bei uns.
Das ist eine richtig coole Idee.
Das muss ich bei uns mal vorschlagen.
Das ist eine richtig geile Idee.
Wenn es bei uns größere, größere Projekte gibt, was muss ich denen mal vorschlagen?
Die sollen immer, wenn irgendwelche größeren Sachen eingeführt werden, einen Chip-It-Sticker drucken.
Ist egal ob man schafft.
Der kann das an der Stelle auch nicht entscheiden.
Das ist ja was Übergreifendes.
Das ist richtig cool.
Die Idee gefällt mir.
Jetzt mache ich das auch einfach selbst für die Sachen, wo ich für zuständig bin.
Jede zehnte Version druck ich aus meinem 3D-Drucker etwas aus für die Handvoll der Leute, die maßgeblich daran beteiligt waren.
Sie können sich das hinstellen.
Nächste ist Version 70.
Wir sind gerade bei 66.
Da betrug ich irgendwas aus meinem 3D-Drucker aus oder so.
Ich finde das ist eine richtig coole Idee mit dieser Chip-It-Plakette.
Ich muss gerade mal was gucken.
Da habe ich eigentlich schon das neueste Update drauf.
Oh, das war jetzt keine so gute Idee, oder?
Wo sieht man denn was man installiert hat?
Wo sieht man seine Windows-Version überhaupt?
WinFair, okay.
WinFair.
Zu Windows-User.
1903.
Ist das das aktuelle?
Oder gibt es schon 1910 oder so?
Was ist denn das neueste?
1910?
Oder was kommt denn als nächstes?
1911?
Was?
1909 müsste doch schon längst draußen sein.
Ah, fertig, hier.
Es ergibt überhaupt keinen Sinn, dass 1909 im November kommt.
Das ergibt überhaupt keinen Sinn.
Wenn es im November kommt, müsste das 1911 heißen.
Nein, das Insider-Programm.
Die kriegen doch nicht mehr ihre eigenen Namenssachen hin.
Daily Meeting, das heißt, sie haben drei Stunden am Tag gelabert,
wenn das drei größere Teams waren.
Going Collins.
Was heißt denn RTM noch mal?
Radio, Televise, Malaysia, ja. Ready to manufacture, ready to market, ready to market.
Ready to manufacture, ja beides, beides.
Okay, dann erzähl uns mal warum es so viele Bugs gibt in Windows.
What? Release to media? Ernsthaft?
Hab ich ja noch nie gehört.
Okay, das benutzt außer ihm auch keiner.
Das hab ich noch nie gehört. Release to media. Vor allem welche Media. Downloads.
Downloads.
Versteh ich aus Microsofts Sicht.
Okay, das ist natürlich eine ziemlich bescheuerte Idee.
Du schmeißt die Tester raus, die sich damit auskennen und lässt Windows Phone Leute jetzt Windows testen.
Big brain.
That's awesome.
Was witzig ist zu Xbox Entwicklung.
Wie gesagt, ich hab selbst niemals für die Xbox entwickelt, aber ich hab letztens was drüber gelesen.
Und zwar, dass zwar auf der Xbox mittlerweile mehr oder weniger ein abgespecktes Windows läuft,
allerdings laufen noch quasi zwei Frameworks oder mehr oder weniger zwei ähnlich Betriebssysteme, zwei so basic Sachen auf der Xbox parallel.
Und diese ganzen Windows Geschichten verwendet auf der Xbox kaum einer.
Die verwenden alle. Ich glaube, wie hieß das? Era und Game. Fuck, ich hab vergessen, wie es heißt. Nicht Gamecube.
Game. Game Core. Kann das sein?
Es muss wohl irgendwas letztens gelesen, es muss wohl irgendwie was Paralleles geben auf der Xbox zu diesem Standard Windows Kram,
den wohl auf der Xbox viele Entwickler gar nicht verwenden, obwohl er da ist.
Deswegen gibt es auch so wenig UWP Spiele.
Die Spiele.
Ja gut, ein Betriebssystem testen auf VMs ist irgendwie das Gegenteil von Big Brain.
Das ist quasi 3-Head. Das ist Small Brain.
Also ein Betriebssystem auf nur auf VMs testen klingt irgendwie nicht so clever.
Das ist clever. Das ist natürlich eine clevere Idee.
Das ist natürlich eine clevere Idee. Man lässt die Leute auf ihrem Arbeitsplatzrechner DevBills benutzen,
dass die sich darüber auskotzen bei den Entwicklern, wenn ihr DevBills nicht richtig funktioniert.
Das finde ich gar nicht schlecht, ehrlich gesagt. Umso mehr Leute den Kram täglich benutzen und Feedback geben, umso besser.
Oder am Ende ein Werkraum.
Heutzutage sind nicht so viele Leute an Microsoft selbst gehostet.
Die Entwicklerinnen und Entwicklern haben nicht so viel auf einen Tester pro Entwickler,
weil sie auf Telemetrie von Windows Insider Builds auskommen.
Windows Insider Builds sind etwas, bei dem du oder ich wieder aufsteigen kannst.
Das ist einfach eine early release Code.
Dann bekommen wir diese Code, wir runnen sie in unsere Box.
Wenn etwas krascht oder etwas brechst, wird es das Microsoft rapportieren.
Das Problem ist, dass die meisten Bugs nicht kraschend sind, sondern dass etwas nicht richtig funktioniert.
Wenn etwas nicht richtig funktioniert, generiert es keine Information, die in die Form von einem Dumpf-File zu Microsoft gehen muss.
Dann können sie aufladen und sagen, oh, da ist mein kraschendes Code, das alles kaputtgebrochen ist.
Aber sie verlassen sich auf eine User, die das rapportieren.
Und die Wahrheit ist, dass viele Windows Insiders diese Probleme nicht rapportieren, unless sie katastrophisch sind.
Das bedeutet, dass nur ein kleiner Teil der Leute, die das Problem betrachten, es tatsächlich rapportieren.
Und auch wenn sie es rapportieren, können sie Microsoft nicht unbedingt darauf achten, wie sie es reparieren müssen,
in einer Art, dass sie wissen können, wo die Bug ist und wie sie es reparieren.
Das sollte dann nicht passieren.
Oh.
Gut.
Du kannst ja auch keinen kompletten Memory-Dumpf ziehen von irgendeinem User.
Soll der da irgendwie seine 8-16 GB RAM hochladen, mit allem Möglichen drinnen?
Das würde ein Teufel tun, meinen kompletten RAM-Inhalt zu Microsoft hochzuladen.
Gibt es dafür nicht AP-Traces?
Ja, so wie ich ihn verstanden habe, meint er das damit.
Diese Sachen werden zu Microsoft hochgeladen.
Allerdings haben sie oftmals das Problem, dass sie die Abhängigkeiten bzw. die Sachen, wie das entstanden ist,
sie sehen zwar den Fehler, können den Fehler nachvollziehen, aber sie wissen, sie kennen die Voraussetzungen nicht genau, wie der entstanden ist.
Das ist anscheinend so das Problem, wenn ich ihn richtig verstehe.
Prime 1996 abonniert auf Stufe 1. Ein richtiges Abo. Mit dem Namen hätte ich eigentlich einen Prime-Sub erwartet mit dem Namen.
Kein richtigen, aber Dankeschön für zwei Monate in Folge.
Und dann sehen wir, wo die meisten Verlusten geschehen. Und schauen wir mal, was die Computer von den Verlusten anbieten, um zu sehen, was da passiert ist.
Und wenn sie den Verlusten fixieren, haben sie keine gute Testbed, um zu verhindern, dass es 100% fixiert wird.
Und dann werden sie die Verlusten anbieten. Und dann werden sie die Verlusten anbieten.
Und dann werden sie die Verlusten anbieten.